how cool denominations and how much love
the show God or was it surprising for
you guys or did you know when you did
this work it was something exceptional
you always hope for everything but you
definitely expect nothing but when
you're this way if you're playing for
the Warriors
there's a chance you might make it to
the championships and so when I feel
like we're working with people like Ryan
Mergen the Steph Curry of TV right now I
feel like okay maybe that these these
things might happen I feel like this is
going well I feel like these things are
really amazing
so you know when it's recognized it's
very validating that you're like okay I
wasn't crazy this was pretty special
that you work Steph Curry into our
interview now just probably made me
happier than anything else that I've
heard today in fact Ryan Murphy Steph
Curry he would he would not understand
that referee would have no idea what
you're talking about
he'd be like huh what she'sshe and
fashion I'm like no no it's too high
you'd be like oh no it's a dude hey I'm
the cast Edgar and the rest of the cast
have you guys had a chance to get back
together have you seen each other during
the week or each other a lot we all
bonded very much during the course of
this very very special experience and
I'm so thrilled for their nominations
not only for their own careers but for
the fact that I you know I get to share
this evening with them and share this
crazy journey you know it's not just me
on the carpet it's all of us kind of you
know sharing it together
how's wedding planning going I wouldn't
recommend doing it and move everything
else
Hey when it rains it pours and I'll take
it I'm doing something like for every
man out there just so you know wedding
planning is a monster isn't it it's a
lot but it's it's a lot of fun we like
throwing a good party so you know a
wedding is no exception
here's the good news it'll end like that
are you prepared for that and then you
have to actually be married you know we
get to play dress up and go to a lot of
life-changing sort of amazing events
like tonight obviously that has a one-up
on this kind of night but all you can do
is breathe and take it in so that's what
I'm trying to do right now
[Applause]
[Music]